the best person to set up
a dual family would be someone like a
truck driver or a [ __ ] door-to-door
salesman
because they're traveling because
they're traveling all over the place
they travel all
you ever have a [ __ ] knock on
your door do you answer the door
to salesmen no will you pretend you
don't home you're at home yeah
exactly do you just say everybody be
quiet it's a [ __ ] the door
trying to sell some [ __ ]
we don't move okay i'll get that do you
open the door you [ __ ] open the door
i want to see what the [ __ ] they got
i asked that [ __ ] on sale first thing i
asked them is that [ __ ] on sale
is it on sale and can i get that [ __ ] on
[ __ ] amazon
i put them on the spot now i control the
[ __ ] sale i control the sale now
you understand i'm controlling that [ __ ]
can i get that [ __ ] on amazon
that [ __ ] on sale like a two for one put
him on the spot now i control the sale
see
i'm controlling the [ __ ] sale you
gotta control
your [ __ ] cell see you gotta control
your travel you gotta control your love
story and you gotta control
living happily and shut the [ __ ] up and
don't tell nobody [ __ ] about what the
[ __ ] you doing
if you want to be happy truly happy
don't give away
all your [ __ ] secrets don't give all
your [ __ ] away if you want that sale
the sale is you selling you your life
is your sale if you don't know how to
sell you guess what
nobody's buying you can't handle a
[ __ ] love story
you can't live happily because you don't
know how to [ __ ] sell you
it's wrong miles is [ __ ] wrong to
cheat on your family with another family
but somehow you've learned to sell
yourself
now you can reapply that [ __ ] in your
occupation
in your circles see how it comes back
around now
you've mastered something that people
are looking for if you can have a
positive spin on that [ __ ]
on all the things we talked about in
this amazing quote come on man
people who who set up dual families they
know where to go
they know where their [ __ ] sails are
at a peak
they go to cities like they like peoria
or scranton and [ __ ] like that scranton
on [ __ ] peoria woo miles yeah
that's what [ __ ] go at to find
extra families that's the hub
that's the [ __ ] miles scranton
and peoria are the hub that's the
perfect word miles
the hub for uh uh the [ __ ]
[ __ ] family's extra family on the
side they caught a family on the side on
the side
okay little family on the side which
came from the root word
uh side chick well i learned i learned
something finally
you come from the side chick the side
chick therefore
the person falls in love with the side
chick and the side chick becomes a side
family you see okay when next time i
roll through here
and they pull that big ass truck they
took out and put the truck right up into
right in front of the house and they
they threw the horn on
the whole family runs outside and [ __ ]
daddy daddy daddy
see and then you [ __ ] up cause you got
four other kids with your other wife
now you calling the kids about the wrong
[ __ ] name you can't live happy like
that